you know I spend most of my years with
startups and then you're getting super
excited about partnering with a giant
you know sometimes it's a healthcare
giant sometimes it's a e-commerce giant
because your dream is to scale it with
with the big guys okay you need to plan
this partnership you need to plan the
pilot you need to validate with your
partner that it's not only about
exercise it's not only about you know
digital lipstick to say that this
solution is now running and both sides
are experiencing this technology you
need from the first moment to make sure
that your partner is willing and with
the right interest to scale it and not
just to say hey I run this this pilot
because I want my organization to be
digital savy and something like that and
in order to do it you need to verify
that you're working with the right
partner you need to plan exactly what
are the outcomes how can we measure
[Music]
success Udi gurri welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for spending
this time with me how are you thanks for
having me exciting and I think it's
always fun you know having like
conversation although only the two of us
knowing that many others will listen
later but yeah I know you're good enough
and I was listening to some some of your
podcast so I know it will be very
personal although we know that so many
others will listen later I think it's
going to be it's going to be a lot of
fun I'm ex to dive in to to the whole
world of of of digital Health with you
and everything that and and your your
your personal Journey leading up to it
and and you know right before we started
you mentioned something that I thought
was very was very nice and and
interesting which was this idea that you
know separation of digital and health
but put together you know the context of
digital Health you're that you're you're
your background is not necessarily
coming from from Healthcare this is
where you are an executive today and
you're working at an incredible company
that that's doing some great impact but
but really your your digital first and
so tell me a little bit about your own
Journey leading up to what you're doing
today cool so I'm Udi and with more than
20 years experience in the tech industry
happened to be around seven years ago
switching to another vertical you know I
did e-commerce I did Telecom I did
different vertical and all of a sudden
by mistake I would say switch to digital
Health um right now I'm leading um the
Israeli team for Elance Health Elance
health is a huge Health Care giant
taking care for more than 406 Million
Lives where their health health plan
were taking care of their health Journey
we would like to be their partner not
only their insurance company but a real
Healthcare partner taking care of you
know their and to the end Journey
especially about myself but let's let's
yeah let's cover the digital Health
thing I think my vision or I hope to be
one day in a situation that we don't
need to say digital Health anymore and
why I'm saying it because think about it
like 20 years ago we start to say hey
we're going to Ecommerce okay and then
we said okay there is the mobile
Revolution let's call it mcommerce and
all these kind of things of bring the
tech into different verticals think
about 10 years ago we sell digital
banking no one is saying digital banking
anymore why because for us it's obvious
that digital banking is banking okay
there is no Banking and digital banking
anymore I think the last vertical to
come and this is like really you know
difficult stuff and and so many reason
why sometimes Healthcare is the last one
to get into the digital Revolution I
assume in five years to come 10 years to
come there will be no more digital
Health it will be just health and this
is exactly what we're doing right now
and this is why I'm so passionate and
and excited about the digital Revolution
into Healthcare um unlike others um
there is huge friction to transform and
to digitize healthare and I think there
are so many good reason why because we
don't want to move too fast when it's
about our health our lives and it's
heavily regulated and I'm happy that
it's regulated because I
want like entities like fdas and legal
and others to be very involved and to
make sure that we're not moving so F so
fast um so many reason why it's like
moving slowly um but I would say slow
slowly but surely and I think you know
the exciting moment that people like me
like others we used to to say we're the
tech guys we're the Dig part of digital
Health are getting you know step by step
into this vertical and I think right now
we are already in this kind of
transition I can see so many things that
we're doing right now compared to five
years ago and I'm sure that it will take
some time and another two years another
five years another 10 years but
Healthcare will be significantly better
compared to current the current state of
healthcare so so what are some of those
things that you're that you're so
excited about so you're me things that
today we're doing in healthcare that
five five or 10 years ago very very
different I would surprise you you know
there are so many people that you know
coming with this kind of vision coming
and say hey in two years to come we will
totally trans translate the human
interaction into Ai and and into the the
next generation of of Technology I'm not
there I am you know 100% entrepreneur
I'm all in about digital and Technology
I think that we need to do it step by
step and there are so many things that
we need to F fix around Healthcare which
are not the latest and greatest and and
the you know top Edge um things about
you know like Ai and llm and I'll start
with you know just saying you know
Healthcare right now is very fragmented
okay it means even in Israel it used to
be you know and everyone is saying hey
we're The Cutting Edge of technology and
digital and we have have Healthcare
databases for more than 20 if not 30
years it's still fragmented it's still
you can go to a doctor and then to a
hospital and some of the data and some
of the interface and some of the
communication between different part
parties it's still broken and still
siloed same also in the US same also in
other parts of the world and to be very
honest also about you know the digital
guys like us we said hey Healthcare is
fragmented let's bring the digital glue
let's bring the latest technology and
let's connect the silos I think right
now we have too many Tech Solutions too
many startups sometimes too many you
know um very Cutting Edge Technologies
but we still fragmented we still lack
platforms and Inter connection between
different solutions so we're still
fragmented let's start with this one and
very like we're standing so much of our
time not only in inventing a new feature
inventing a new product or inventing a
new solution but spend most of our time
about integrating new ideas into one
platform because we want to fix it we
want your next journey into Healthcare
to be not fragmented before the digital
age so surprisingly or not it's not only
about the latest and greatest of AI and
Technology I think the magic is about
highly integrating different solutions
into one platform interesting so you're
essentially what I'm no when if I'm
paraphrasing you're you're you're saying
that while there's a lot of Novel
solutions that that are looking at how
do we improve I guess the end point sort
of like in security like the endpoint
security you're talking about that we're
what we're still lacking is on a on a
very infrastructure level the pipes that
connect these different data points and
connect these platforms to be able to
transmit the data and make sense of the
data as a whole and not just the
fragmentation of data points and I guess
it makes sense because Healthcare is a
lot about synthesizing a lot of signals
to make a rational decision right
exactly you nail it and you know let's
think about like what we're doing here
in Israel for El Health okay the best
way to describe what we're doing is some
kind of you know supply and demand okay
elvin's Health leadership came here
about four years ago fell in love with
you know the passion and the
opportunities Tech opportunities in
Israel and decided that we should be
some kind of boots in the ground and
connect between the supply and the
demand there is definitely amazing
supply of new ideas Technologies
products in Israel and we should connect
it with the demand with business owners
all over the US especially with elvan
health that looking for the next big
thing or other Solutions I do feel right
now that our challenge is not only
validating and and accelerating
different solutions but also thinking
about how can we integrate this specific
amazing solution into one platform into
one cohesive solution okay and we need
to do it both because it's one thing you
know to meet an Israeli startup and to
understand to do some kind of tech due
diligence and bu bu due diligence and
then build the pilots you know Israel is
a the masters of pilots and prototypes
and these kind of things the magic
happen when you see the full picture and
you do understand not only how to win
the pilot and to win the tech but also
to highly integrated into the platform
and the endtoend system for a giant like
elevant Health but also for other giants
like hospitals and other health
Healthcare players and I found it in the
last few years that I think more and
more people especially you know highly
passionate Israelis do understand that
it's not only about you know the next
big thing it's about how can I Implement
validate have like quantitive results
and high integration with for my
solution into the big mother boat which
is the healthcare industry very cool and
so tell me a little bit about the from a
business perspective your experience
between you mentioned your transition
from from Ecom to to H to Telecom and
now to to healthcare so you've seen
different types of I guess ecosystems
and industries they have different
priorities where business lies versus
you know the different constraints of
the market and and we were speaking
about this a little bit before the
recording as well what is what is your
perception of of of the world in
healthcare it's it's interesting and I
think I'll use you know the your example
of you know bringing e-commerce as an
example for another article that
validate their IT solutions to
healthcare okay people are sometimes
thinking okay this is like great idea
this is great product all I need is a
prototype and to test it and to make
sure that the customer is satisfied and
I'm good to go but also when we are
bringing new latest and greatest
solution in the e-commerce industry it
won't be that another day later Amazon
will implement it and will use it they
will do AB testing and validate and see
some quantitive value based on this
product it's the same with Healthcare we
can't just say hey but this doctor is
excited or this patient or this member
is super happy with this solution we
need to play the same game and to have
very quantitative results and value in
order to jump from just a pilot and just
prototype into a large scale solution
and unlike e-commerce although in
e-commerce and and others they will do
ADB testing they will do maybe you know
day-to-day testing in order not only to
validate but to get this solution into
the very optimized you know H place and
and and solutioning same also with
Healthcare but Healthcare do bring and
we're lucky to have this kind of
clinical trial almost Heritage okay of
checking and validating each and every
solution we need to win both the patient
he should be in love and happy with the
solution we need to win the doctor The
Physician the hospital but we also need
to win quantitive clinical value okay
and for this one you need to design your
pilot you need to design your solution
in order that you should have not only
KP K just you know high level kpis very
measurable outcomes clinical outcomes
cost of care outcomes dollar outcomes in
order to make sure that your solution is
not only nice is not only you know make
people happy but with very validated
results and I think you know some people
do have you know some concerns or or
saying hey but Health Care should be
about just bring me a good solution and
bring me better health I think it's we
should also validate it and be very
measurable with our outcomes otherwise
we can scale any solution just because
we're happy about it or excited about it
and so what what are the pitfalls with
not doing that what have you observed
our are I guess signs or symptoms or
know indicators that you know one is not
thinking in this way because it sounds
like you've you're speaking from
experience of of why this is especially
important here absolutely and you know I
spend most of my years with startups and
then you're getting super excited about
partnering with a giant you know
sometimes it's a healthcare giant
sometimes it's a e-commerce giant
because your dream is to scale it with
with the big guys okay you need to plan
this partnership you need to plan the
pilot you need to validate with your
partner that it's not only about
exercise it's not only about you know
digital lipstick to say that this
solution is now running and both sides
are experiencing this technology you
need from the first moment to make sure
that your partner is willing and with
the right interest to scale it and not
just to say hey I run this this pilot
because I want my organization to be
digital savy and something like that and
in order to do it you need to verify
that you're working with the right
partner you need to plan exactly what
are the outcomes how can we measure
success is it just about the happiness
of the patient the happiness of the
doctor the happiness of the hel plan or
is it like validated results that we can
move the needle and make sure that this
solution is make sense economically and
you know getting into the economics of
healthcare first it's fascinating
because that's the way we're validating
the spend of dollars in healthcare but
when you nail it and we you have the
right experience and the right experts
to have this kind of Economics
discussion about your solution you're in
the right way it will take you a few
times and few iterations you know to fix
and to get to the right numbers and to
fix your product in order that people
won't be just satisfied but also to to
to show some economic results but when
you're there or almost there this is
like the Magic Moment of each and every
product this is where we're heading and
both from the startup side but also from
the last few years that I'm spending
with elvin's he I love it what what
really gets you excited today in in your
line of work so what is it about what
you do that really you know sets you up
on fire oo um I think it's about me I'm
both very tacky you know going back you
know tens of years I was always excited
about you know technology and products
I'm some kind of a builder um on the
other hand I am more excited about you
know integrating integrating not only
product and solutions and Technologies
but also people and organization and
different entities into one solution so
for me the Magic Moment is you know
falling in love with specific technology
but not only because of the techn ol
because of the potential and when you
can connect going back to supply and
demand you can connect with highly
passionate you know Israeli startup
coming with interesting technology and
knowing that this one can move the
needle with a business partner there in
the US and then walking the talk because
you can do it in a matter of weeks
sometimes not month it takes between one
to three years to validate to walk the
talk to fix so many things but the magic
moment that you understand that this is
not just a pilot this is something that
you can scale this is something that can
go to the hands of millions of lives I
think this this is the Magic Moment
especially with Healthcare especially
when you know it's it's about others
lives and in the case of elvin's Health
but also with other us Healthcare giants
like it's a matter of millions of lives
that you can impact and so for for
aspiring entrepreneurs that are now they
finishing their army service or or
university around the world what you
know how how should they be thinking
about you know digital health or health
because we perhaps won't have to call it
digital Health in the future how should
yeah we can still call it we can still
call it digital Health but yeah one day
let's let's connect when when we can
remove the digital but yeah totally I I
think you know my advice will be think
like a anist okay Healthcare is
complicated digital health is a
multidisciplinary thinking you need to
be some kind of endtoend
thinker um to combine together or to
compile so many clinical insights Tech
insights business in in insights I think
it's like yeah you can say it on in in
each and every vertical but especially
with Healthcare especially with digital
health you should have your skill set
ready to have different conversation
with so many experts in so many fields
and the keys to success is not only to
fall in love with the the tech size this
side this is like the easiest part
because where Israel is we're always in
love with our solution with the latest
and greatest in some cases with deep
technology that we can bring but also to
combine it with business thinking with
listening to others to other
experts and to understand the art of
possible and like Israelis we always
like dream about the next big thing and
how can we move fast forward we need
sometimes to B it with other expertise
like clinical expertise and business
expertise only when you're you can
balance it and work with others and
partner with others okay and especially
with Healthcare especially with digital
Health there you can succeed success be
successful as a startup if you're not
partnering with ex a giant like Elvin
health or with other Giants I think not
like only very few startups are really
doing good with Partnerships and we
should be much much better with our
Partnerships skill set udy I really want
to thank you for spending this this time
with me it was it was lovely and and so
interesting to hear your perspective Ive
and and clear passion for what you're
doing and I think the fact that you've
had this progression over these
different Industries just speaks volumes
to to why why why you're here and why
you're doing what you're doing which I
think is really really awesome so I
really appreciate your time it felt like
five minutes and said for me for me it
was
three it was a lot of fun anyway just
just Target part one okay and we'll do
part two exactly thank you so much UD
thanks Michael pleasure really pleasure
[Music]